يكسر القلب حيث لم يكن لديك الوقت و
اترك أحفاد أحفادهم يمشون الآن
في جميع انحاء المدينة
دعنا نحاول معرفة مكان الاتصال
غضب العجز لا أعرف
نشرت هنا ثم سأكون قطة ونعم
لدي لقطات من اليسار حيا كله
أخرج كل الأشياء المتبقية من العفاريت و
لا يوجد شيء في الملجأ
ولكن مات كثير من الناس صغارا ومن أجل
بالأمس لأكل الحلي كان سيكون تقريبًا
12-20 12-30
إلى مدرستنا ، غمرت أرضية الصاروخ
لوحة الهواء الأنابيب لوحة الأرض
كانت الأجزاء الموجودة على المدرسة السوداء لرون العمود
كان الضحايا ويجمعوننا بين الأزواج الصعبة التي لم تفعل ذلك
ينام يملأ نلتقطها نحن بدائيون
أمر رازق ألف نادرا الدفاع
مناطقهم و
مايز أطلق النار لخمسة أشخاص لرحلات sim i k
أعطيتنا أيضًا صواريخ عنقودية
شحنة